over there
so we celebrated national cuban sandwich
day recently and rocky is introducing us
to her favorite local spot where you can
enjoy the flavors of cuba all year round
so when i moved to las vegas back in
2019 i was looking for some good
authentic cuban food and i found zach
and kobani bad and he's been blessing me
ever since so we've been celebrating the
cuban sandwich recently exactly what is
that what is the culture behind it so
the coach behind cuba sandwiches you
have a typical miami style keeper
sandwich and a tampa style called eboard
okay and here we go chef is going to
actually show you how to assemble each
of these sandwiches so here we go press
everybody
come on over so you'll see what chef is
doing he has our meat there on the
bottom he's topping it with the mustard
sauce
now he's helping rookie put the bread on
top there's a mustard sauce then we're
also going to put it right here on the
grill
flat grill we're going to put a little
garlic butter on top
to level off that sandwich exactly spice
it up perfect yep
there we go closed down
and as you'll see
most cupid sandwiches are done pressed
which is what we do it here for all our
sandwiches i love this okay now while
that's cooking let's talk about the dish
itself because i see plantains on the
side and you know that is my favorite
mine too so most these are plantain
chips that go with all of our sandwiches
um chef is uh adding a mojo sauce most
authentic cubans they'll use those the
mojo sauce to dip their plantain chips
you guys go ahead and check it out
listen i'm sorry i couldn't help myself
oh my god oh my gosh so good okay so
tell us about more about kuvanida right
so we initially opened in 2019 we have a
location in fort apache uh in our
summerlin area and when we opened over
there we got a lot of influx of hispanic
people coming who lived in henderson so
we thought hey if this location open uh
why not you know why not come over here
and service the people over here so look
you gotta you have some guests over here
we're trying we opened up last week on
monday um so we've had one week of soft
openings so hopefully when more people
hear about the world gets out and this
is the bigger location correct this
location is uh about double the size of
the one on florida bashing all right
double the size double the food there we
go yeah yeah
i love it okay so kobani kubani died
cuban sandwiches what are some other
authentic dishes that we can get some
authentic dishes that chef has here is
aropa vieja also with our [ __ ] we
have a lechon with immortals which is
our cuba style rice which comes with
black beans and also roasted pork um
chef also has a fried alligator by the
way oh okay okay
artificial definitely
no other dishes yes chef also has a
fried alligator that is excellent and he
has several other obviously plantains
you know you can't have an authentic
cuban restaurant exactly speaking of
plantains um
i i need one container for sure i need
this container
full of fried plants i got you that's no
problem we got it all right
here in henderson you guys this is so
good this food is authentic thank you
chef
i'll take this too okay
i'll send it back to you guys